In this section on social behavior, we've discussed attraction, liking, and
love. We see that we tend to be attracted to people with average and
symmetrical faces. And on a side note, we tend to be attracted to be people and
gravitate towards people who are as attractive as we are ourselves. We also
discussed the fact that when choosing mates, we tend to select individuals who
are similar to us, in a variety of characteristics, such as ethnicity,
socioeconomic status, even religious affiliation. And finally we talked about
what is love, and the different types of love. Now we're going to end this
lesson with an interview with Dr Markie Blemer/g, who is going to talk to us
about two fast-growing areas of discussion in psychology. That's gender, as
well as technology and relationships.